the spring league of the 2021 st
louis corporate chess league comes to an
end as the final four teams meet
with special commentator grand master
josh friedel
it's all today on the spring
championship
everyone this is gm josh fidel
and today i'll be doing commentary on
the corporate chess league finals
so hopefully you guys will enjoy that
um so to this
has been going on for quite a while and
today is the final day so
there was first a grand prix where you
had
um there was a grand prix league final
and the standings in the end
the qualifiers were edwin jones wwt
enterprise and merits uh
behind them were ascension buyer express
scripts and other teams
so the format for the finals is you have
a round robin
match point and then the tie breaks are
by match points
not guy game points so if a team wins
three uh
four zero there are four boards per
match if they win four zero it's the
same as two and a half
half one and a half and the team that
wins the most match points so if you go
three and oh and no other and
you beat all the other teams you win uh
is the basic gist if you have two
or more teams tying if you have a couple
teams time you have an armageddon tie
break between one player and each team
and the winner will have the name
engraved on that chessboard you saw
which is pretty cool
so that's kind of how it all works
and we're going to see the game start in
a little bit
[Music]
but yeah so the first pairings we have
are we have
edward jones is going to play merits
they're going to be white meaning their
first two boards get white
and then boards three and four get black
and worldwide technology plays
enterprise
and there again the first two boards get
white and then the last two boards get
three boards three and four get black is
how it works
uh so welcome everyone uh i'll be mostly
doing commentary but i will see the
youtube chat if you have a particular
question or something like that
um but yeah we have a few minutes till
they start i'm gonna start following the
counts
um but yeah feel free to
ask questions or do anything of that
nature
uh but yeah i have to follow these
accounts
unfortunately it doesn't let you follow
them when they're offline so
if uh
all right hopefully this is all right
hopefully this is going to work
yeah because i would have followed these
accounts ahead of time but it makes it a
little bit tricky
but yeah i'll be basically doing this
until they start
all right got most of them followed that
should start us off
um but yeah should be
should be pretty interesting uh all
right alex yeah alex is
uh currently playing uh alex kirkford so
best of luck to you
all right so we're gonna start in just a
few minutes
and yeah don't worry about the board it
should fix itself when uh
multiple games start but
let us see
all right
all right
yeah so it should fix itself uh pretty
soon when we start
going uh just a couple of minutes left
uh but yeah it should be interesting so
keep in mind like these players so
basically these are
uh players at the various companies
they're top players from them
uh from what i know we have quite a few
like master level players
and people like that uh so it's by no
means weak but it's definitely like not
professional players so it's a little
different from watching
it's kind of a change of pace from
watching like top gm's play or even
watching im's
fm's but it's still like you can learn a
lot from these games and obviously
they're all still quite good players so
it's
should be interesting to do commentary
on it i've never really followed it to
be honest
but it should be really interesting to
watch
and i find that the games can often be
quite interesting so
we shall see
[Music]
and
alright
because a couple people haven't logged
in yet so i'll make sure i get
follows
okay almost everyone
and the game should start up in just a
minute and then the layout will look a
lot nicer
and everything will start so
at least i hope so i can always take a
second to fix it but
uh for those who are curious actually
you can actually see the rules here
so the first round will begin in just a
minute at 6 15.
then the next one is 6 645. keep in mind
their game's in 10 with no increments so
we're gonna see a lot of time scrambles
and probably lots of flagging
uh and then round three at 7 15 a.m 7 15
p.m sorry central time
only match points and it's around robin
so
uh that is the current format
and we should be seeing go uh games come
up
very soon
okay one player i still can't follow i'm
assuming they're not here yet
and we will see
all right
okay
yeah everything's going well
all right
so it should start any second
i'm following all the players so it
should automatically do it
all right
wait i'm still missing someone who am i
missing
uh this okay nope
there we go okay now i'm following 12
people which should
make us all sets so hopefully they get
started pretty soon
that's at least the plan but looks like
there's a delay for one moment
all right here we go we have one game
going
hopefully there are more yeah okay
so hopefully the layout's fixed now yes
it should be
fine there we go
okay
okay so we're seeing guys play pretty
fast again it's 10-0
so we'll have to see this is vishal
against maybe swap so let's see
and again i i'll uh announce their real
names and stuff when we have winners and
things like this
so yeah e3 in general i'm not a huge fan
of like in general i prefer to just
play it like a grunfeld basically
reversed with bishop g2 and castles
but e3 is of course playable and yeah
just a normalish position
um it's kind of hard so i'm gonna just
browse to see what positions we have
that are kind of interesting
this looks like a queen c2 banco which
is always kind of interesting
oh they drew already that was fast
uh okay uh accelerated dragon
which position looks the most
interesting let's go with this one this
one looks kind of cool so
we have a
uh king's indian with bishop g5
and queen d2 so this is a very
aggressive uh way to play
so white black castles here which can't
be too bad but in general i definitely
like playing h6 in a position like this
because then
first of all if there's a pawn here the
bishop sometimes can drop back more
easily
uh but here there isn't so it's hard for
the bishop to just drop back too safely
uh i guess it can draw back here right
but then it's got kind of
asking to get hit with e5 someday um
but in general i don't like castling
because now the bishop can always go
here and you can never play h6 it's just
a little bit
uh a little bit uh less ideal
and also white can just start launching
an attack
so black's trying to get counter play of
their own with b5 this is quite logical
um white plays h4 so white's really just
going for the direct attack
and there's really no reason why this
shouldn't be at least playable because
after here the problem black has is that
if knight takes you can play rook takes
followed by queen g5 and the game's
actually over so h5 is a very very
serious threat here
so black chooses to play e6 and white
chooses to play h5 so white's basically
ignoring what black's doing and claiming
that this threat is going to be too
strong
to be fair after takes takes cakes king
takes queen check the king could drop
back and there's nothing horrible going
on
but it's also kind of a permanently
unsafe king
and the problem is also that you have to
watch out for the knight getting traded
off on f6 as well
which could be a big another big problem
so it's kind of like a brute force type
of attack but sometimes these
these attacks can be quite annoying to
face
so i don't know exactly like what what
should have been done earlier like maybe
in this position you could think about
something quicker like maybe playing e6
right away uh or trying to be a little
faster
a6 is just a little bit too slow so
white actually goes for this capture
which is incredibly risky but i guess
playable
so yeah here here you can't go for this
because there's a queen covering the
square now that the pawn on e6
so that's one thing however after takes
now you have to if knight takes then
queen here is just going to be
devastating right so you have to take
with the king
uh but here there's all sorts of issues
g4 is played right
and now the knight has to retreat and
then you can give a check here and then
knight here
and all of a sudden that's a lot of
pieces aimed at that king so probably
black would have to go night here
but i would suspect that after knight g5
trying to target this pawn
it's simply going to be winning uh would
be my guess
so i'm really not exactly sure what the
plan would be after
that so i think this is already really
problematic for black
you have to be very cautious when you
face this kind of attack and as we saw
playing h6 earlier would have avoided
this just in general
so it definitely makes things a little
bit better
um so yeah we can check back on this
like
but this looks alright it's going to be
bad because knight here queen check
knight e4 you have to play 97 right i
mean i guess technically here doesn't
get you mated maybe you have to consider
that
um because the hill idea is that then if
you play
knight takes f6 queen takes f6 queen
takes check king here you're not getting
mated
yet it does look terrible but you're not
mated
so maybe that's what you have to try but
you definitely have to play knight back
here right if you lose the piece the
problem is you're still getting attacked
you're you're not gonna necessarily
you're gonna lose a piece but probably
get made it later anyway so i think you
have to at least try it
even though it's very likely losing in
some fashion
but yeah you have to be careful of these
kind of attacks so we can check out
another game
let me just quickly browse to see if
there's any that catch my eye
um
wow some very interesting games okay
all right well we have this other one so
as we saw like lots of stuff happened
here they have this relatively normal
position i guess
white's a little bit passive but nothing
crazy
and then queen out knight takes bishop
c4
bishop takes f6 so usually allowing
bishop takes f6 in a situation like this
is really not ideal so
i i would say that in general black
should not give up this bishop
uh this bishop is quite strong so even
though you lose a tempo going back it's
probably the better choice
and then c4 would be a decent try for
white so believe it or not like blacks
white's position black white's position
is not nearly as bad as it looks
one other try you could do is something
like c4 to shut down this bishop that
move i actually kind of like
um i don't know whether you want to take
the knight first that's actually a
trickier question but in general i like
shutting down this bishop
because once the bishop opens like
happened in the game it's going to be
a little bit tricky black could have
thought about d4 as well because if
takes you can take this rook
but i don't know exactly
the problem with d4 of course is you
threaten nothing but it still looks like
probably a better try because after
queen here
bishop f6 pawn f6 takes here i think
that white's position should probably
just be good
uh there's still some trickiness on the
king side i suppose so queen takes c5
takes qui takes a7 so white's just
grabbing everything so the real question
is whether black can create
enough counter threats on the king side
but i would suspect that it's very
difficult to actually create dangerous
threats here
it just takes too many moves to attack
this h2 pawn
so rook f3 was tried rook a2 is a very
clever move trying to guard this pawn
i don't know if white's rating is really
800 but they're playing quite well for
this level
but yeah overall this is probably going
to be
too much so bishop g2 happened king g2
queen f3 check
came back to g1 h5 so black's trying to
do this and really
the main task for white here is to find
any way to stop
h4 h3 because that's the only bad thing
that can happen
one option is simply to play h4 this is
maybe the simplest but then you do have
to worry about rookie four and then
takes
they're going for queen d4 which i don't
know about ah but after rookie four
there's queen d1 queen d1 is a very nice
move and that should be
mostly good because if here if you try
to take i can take with the pawn not the
rook
and everything's defended so yeah queen
here looks like a very very strong move
and that should probably do it
uh yeah i mean this is gonna be too many
pawns in a rook end game
so a very nice play uh
we should probably check out this attack
although it looks like no they just lost
a piece
so like in the game i was going over
before
yeah i mean they just ended up
sacrificing a piece but probably they
had to i would have tried knight back
after g4
even if i lose right like i feel like if
i give up a piece i'm just gonna lose
anyway
but yeah this is
yeah so even in this position maybe e4
would be even more devastating
uh because you don't allow the bishop to
come back oh wait
um there's a pawn here no no sorry
i was confused yeah probably you should
just take this and then queen c3 check
is just gonna be
horribly horribly painful
but okay they went for this and queen h6
which is also good enough yeah i mean
this is a piece up right
so a piece up with an attack i think
that probably this will be too strong
for white
so let's see let us go back
okay so this one we have a rook end game
where it's up one pawn
but it's probably good enough because
this pawn is kind of weak right
so this rook just stays behind this pond
and then this pawn starts going
uh i don't know actually i don't know if
i would have played h4 right away
because this is kind of annoying so
maybe you can try
um trying to decide if
this is a moment to play e5 though the
problem is takes takes and then this
king's to open so that's probably not
good
so probably you should try kink here
followed by d5 at some point maybe not
right away like
after you distract the rook yeah not so
easy actually because
you can you can't really push your pawns
or do anything interesting over there
so h4 rook back so now the problem is
you're just going to play rook h2 and
take that pawn
so check in here but this you should be
able to grab that pawn now yeah
so this should probably be very drush uh
all right
yeah you can take this pawn this is this
king upon him game is certainly not
going to be
any kind of trouble you can also delay
it i suppose with f5
yeah there's nothing wrong with doing
this probably because if d5
if d5 takes you're still way in time if
if
after rook takes king takes d4 the king
comes back so this should be very
drawish we can check on it later i guess
this is
still winning okay let's see ooh
this looks like fun oh but it's just
like upper rook
wait so how'd this happen so we had this
position which is already kind of tough
i don't think there's a bitcoin prize
but
so bishop back i don't know if that was
sarcasm i'm very slow
so yeah bishop g2 though is probably not
a good move uh so
in this position you have to be very
careful to control all these squares and
what that means is you need to keep your
bishop
so i don't know exactly what i would
play here but i would even consider
maybe even bishop back here if i if you
need to
try to double rooks on the e pawn i
don't know maybe knight e4 and then try
to get rid of this knight knight e2 is
also a move to consider but you
basically you can never ever give up
this bishop because what happens now is
the queen comes to c6 and this is a
thing right
so white tries f3 which is very painful
but the whole point is that if you try
to play knight e4 i play f5 and i win a
piece
if rook here f5 i went a piece maybe
this would be what i would try but it
looks kind of atrocious right and at the
very least knight here is going to win
material
a lot of material i guess just an
exchange but it's still plenty good
enough right
but yeah f3 is not going help uh this is
just too much
so white goes for knight takes d3
probably not the only way but it
definitely makes sense trying to grab an
extra pawn
and now you're up in exchange in two
pawns so this is winning for black we
don't have to stay here
uh okay
i'm just picking games that look kind of
interesting all right so this is just
over
uh okay yeah let's still up a piece
all right we're gonna go here
so white's up a pawn in this end game
but i don't think it's so easy because
you can do something like this and try
to blockade on these
dark squares and that's going to be very
very pesky
uh i guess the main drawback though is
this knight where is this knight going
because this knight has no squares and
it can't be defended
by a piece so
i don't know if i were white here i
would probably play king c3
ah but then there's a check but maybe
you don't care about the check
i don't know maybe just a move like
rookie one because then you're
discouraging king c5 because of here
and if you try to play rook c7 i could
think about trying to put pressure on
this knight maybe
because that knight just doesn't have a
square right after king here the only
reason you don't lose a piece is because
you have this move
um and you kind of save your piece but
it's uh that knight leftly looks a
little scratchy so he tries this instead
so he's covering the b5 square so you
can't go there but i can play king
c5 which probably you have to if you try
to go this way i can play f4 check and
take the knight
so you have to play king c5 i would
imagine
um but then the question is what happens
so king c5
probably you should go back right like
trying to go here and maybe try to go
here
although rookie four there is knight f5
for the moment
but it still looks very very dicey to
say the least maybe even
ah maybe you can even go here so king c5
rookie one
rook here maybe yeah king c54 rookie one
i like
rook c7 maybe you can even play d6
because the point is that you king can't
take because king takes knight and if
you move the rook
then maybe just rook here is annoying
because i guess you can take but then i
just start taking all your guys
and it looks very very painful
so rookie one tried i mean again d6 is
not necessary right you don't have to
play with d6 and maybe that means you
shouldn't
um but i don't know i mean the problem
is if you give black
time they'll play v5 it's not like you
can have this knight trapped for all of
eternity right and if you give them time
with like rookie four they can maybe
even try this
and put the knight on d6 so i think that
okay they just go for this but now
rookie seven just looks very very strong
you may save your knight but you're
going to lose all your pawns
so they're taking their time they're
getting lower on the clock
yeah most of these games are pretty much
one-sided at this point
yeah rookie seven yeah this is pretty
good play honestly like by both sides
are really
are really playing well like black's
resisting well but they also have a
tough two
knight b5 checks and both i miss this
because then at pawn takes you can play
king check in this rook hang so after an
ip5 check you have to move your king
and then maybe knight d6 and i grab this
pawn it's still bad right but
uh maybe knight here you can go here ah
but this is clearly miss so this is very
clever this move
i completely missed this resource so
maybe black white should actually go
here
which looks pointless but the idea is
that if you try a6
then i go here so probably after a4 you
should play just rook c7 and life kind
of continues
but all right he doesn't play it but he
plays king there first but i think
knight db5 check was a really really
annoying move
um yeah knight b5 check would have been
really really annoying
so he goes for it now but the problem
with it now is that
it doesn't really do that much the king
just kind of moves i guess you have rook
c7 after but
oh no then check right so like say you
play king b4
rook c7 knight rook check no matter
where the king moves to attack the rook
you check it and then take this knight
so probably after here the knight has to
go back or go here and then you can just
start taking
yeah this is pretty lost
that's funny ruckus yeah
but yeah this is a kill a killer a cool
tactic because here looks like a clever
move to try to hold on to pawns but this
rook
check and rook check tactic ah but wait
a second i
missed something rook check rook check
there is king here
which maybe means the king should have
actually moved back to d2 rather than b4
which is really funny
because rook c7 check here check here
the problem is that in that position
even if i just play king takes knight
king takes bishop d6 you're dead that's
the problem
because then i can bring my king in and
pawn up and it's pretty bad
so this this wouldn't have really saved
black anyway but
it is funny so yeah i mean black has to
just get his rook active and pray
basically so something like rook f8
f3 rook here trying to go here try to
get the knight in like you just have to
get as active as you possibly can
in a position like this because you're
just down so many guys
and probably to be perfectly honest yeah
i mean the problem is you play passively
this is just gonna kill you right
but okay it's already a pretty tough
position um
yeah the other games are pretty much or
let's see alex kurford against rounder
okay
all right so this game we had a stone
wall
uh alright
queen takes c3 c4 e6
e4 so
this is probably just pretty good for
white because you you have like
the pawns kind of rolling and you have a
very very nice attack on the king side
and the queen side counter play is very
slow
so in general this is not the kind of
thing you want to allow when you're
black
um but okay so
here yeah b3 in general again i like i
prefer just leaving the queensland alone
when you have a side your worst you just
kind of leave it alone so
there are lots of ways you can kind of
play this trying to play with f5 is kind
of interesting but you can even play e5
force the knight back and just start
launching your puns and quite honestly
these kind of positions are unusually
impossible to defend maybe f5's only try
but it's like if white ever gets an f5
it's just kind of toast
even e5 and then f5 just a pawn sack gf
g4
is probably just crushing quite honestly
those positions tend to be really bad so
okay playing this way is also possible
uh but here maybe you could have tried
taking knight d6 it's still probably
good okay
but in the end yeah white got attacked
that was way too strong
and that is checkmate yeah was this the
end
okay
hmm wondering if they panicked here like
it's it's pretty bad though this is a
thing
no this is lost okay doesn't matter
okay so white wins and then the only
game going is this one so we have this
end game
i don't know okay ah thank you so
here
uh but the fact is that quite often i'm
never i'm not sure right
and i don't know
it's funny it's a habit now all right
okay so we're here and yeah black's
king's very active which is nice the the
kind of the issue here is that the black
rook can't really get in the game
so even though you have this kind of
active king inactive knight it's very
hard to make real counterplay because
you just can't get in the game
that being said when you have an active
king like this you always have counter
chances
of some kind so
just something to keep in mind
yeah i didn't think there was any
bitcoin but
okay so yeah d7 is coming
and it looks pretty good because the
problem is you just can't really get
counter play here so
king e5 yeah and you can basically give
up this pawn if you want to
you don't really have to now but yeah
and just okay
yeah and now the pawn's just gonna
launch and it's oh it's a flag as well
so that was that um
okay so as the standings went
we have edward jones because vishal
alex kirford and fishers of men won
their games they won their match against
maritz and
worldwide technology tied their match
against enterprise
uh because worldwide technology won on
boards two and four but lost on boards
one and three
so that match was a tie so right now
edward jones is in the clear lead
in the next match they get black meaning
their top two boards get black
against enterprise and
worldwide technology gets white against
merits
so that's coming up in just five minutes
or so
so if you'd like weekend
we can check out a couple of these games
we didn't get to look at as closely so
let's see so
yeah the way this one was was pretty
one-sided i think
so let's see this one ah so let's see
how this end game finished so
takes king here
because i didn't expect one side to win
this end game so takes takes d5
oh they're starting already nice never
mind we're gonna
look at new games all right
so let's see so we have the current
match that is
that is going on we have let me
check this out
so yeah we have enterprise playing
against edward jones is already
happening
so let's check that out so ah we have an
elephant gambit yeah this is not a very
common line but yet
takes on d5 here queen e2 is one of the
one of the decent ways you can play
against this uh you have quite a few to
be perfectly honest there are lots of
decent lines here but taking and then
queen e2 is definitely quite
quite good because you basically have a
position where you're up a pawn in the
center
and there's not a lot of compensation
here so probably something like d3 comes
next and you're trying to get pieces in
so it's kind of a cool line but i would
say the elephant in general doesn't
really
get too much
so d3
yeah and this is a very difficult
position because the problem is that
if we trade i can just take the queen
say and take on d3 and i'm just up a
very very clear pawn
uh if you try to attack this knight with
one of these moves i can always move it
in it
and i can just move the knight somewhere
i don't have to try anything fancy
although knight takes e4 works as well
because of queen ticks i take here
so 97 and now you just take a central
pawn so this is just two central pawns
up
so this position is quite one-sided but
that's kind of what happens sometimes
you play a gambit and if your opponent
handles it correctly you feel
a little bit bad but it doesn't mean
that playing gamuts is bad itself
it's just you want to choose them wisely
because
the elephant in general is just not a
very sound gambit so choosing sound
gambits
and using them at the right moments is
an important thing
but yeah here i mean lights up two puns
and there's nothing really wrong with
their position either they can play here
maybe then queen e5 although it's not a
big deal you just go back
bishop f4 is also just very solid and
very good you have
many options here i think so
let us see if there's anything
oh we have this this craziness wow this
is a fun game
okay let's check it out so we have a
king's gambit always a good start
and g5 all right so we have this is the
main the main deal right you can play
other
moves here i've always played d5 because
i'm kind of
not someone who likes to take gambits
usually i i'd like you can have my pawn
back
but g5 is kind of the really principled
aggressive way to play and this line is
really really crazy so i don't exactly
know how this goes
i don't think this is how people usually
play though because here you can play
bishop c4 and this pawn is
quite weak like you can play net h6 but
it's not really a movie you'd love to
play
um so i don't know if this is what the
advisable thing i think white also
usually goes here if i'm not mistaken
um but again i'm not really up on my
king's gambit theory to be perfectly
honest
but okay so white go black goes for the
ultimate greed right they're just gonna
take this knight which is fair enough i
mean
you don't have to but at the same time
if you don't try to trap this knight
white's just gonna take here and you're
gonna feel bad about your life kind of
right
so f6 bishop takes f4
takes on g5 bishop takes you can also
take with the pawn
uh i kind of like taking with the pawn
because you restrict this knight a lot
which is kind of nice but bishop takes
is a temple move but after bishop here i
feel like you're gonna end up trading
pieces which is not what dwight wants
so that's kind of what happened so i i
prefer taking with the pun
because you restrict more and you don't
necessarily initiate trades
so bishop g7 but okay queen d2 nothing
horrible has happened of course
it's just a complete mess so c6
castles so in general one of the moves i
really like to play early is move like
bishop c4 because it prevents bishop e6
and the bishop on c4 is such a powerful
piece because you're going to play
rook f1 and maybe use the f7 square
there's just so many things that can go
wrong for black
so i would fight to put the bishop here
as early as i can to make sure black
can't play bishop e6
at least not easily so castles because
here for example bishop e6 is a move and
maybe it's not
the end of the world but i i don't like
having this c4 score taken away
so that's kind of why i like this move
uh but again
it's a it's a rapid game right so you're
just trying to develop your pieces
and white goes to d3 anyway and then on
f8 it's actually not that bad it
controls the pawn it controls the square
but okay now d5 is going to be a bit of
a problem though because the rook on f1
is really strong so yeah i have a
feeling that black should
something there should be some kind of
sacrifice here that's very strong so
white just builds in a normal way which
is also playable i suppose
e5 okay yeah e5 has to be played at some
point i was considering e5 even here
with the idea that if you try to take it
and i take and even bishop e4 or queen
here bishop b4
you're gonna get a big initiative here
the extra piece is nice but quite
frankly that king on e8 is very scary so
here
the drawback to doing it this way is
that black can think about castling at
some point
but it is going to be tricky so d6 i
don't know about but if you take here
i think it's pretty good because if pawn
takes them bishop e4
and that that c6 pawn is actually quite
a
quite a pest a pest for black as in it's
very annoying to
have to defend all the time so i really
like that
d6 is really an all for an all or
nothing thing
but after kwe takes d6 i don't quite see
the tactic because if rook takes f7 i
think you can take and if check you can
go kink here maybe they miss this it's
very possible
that they had this tactic in mind and
now they realize it doesn't work
and the problem is if you try to do it
in the reverse order queen takes queen
is a check
so you don't get to be sneaky and play
bishop c4 first they're going for it but
i don't
quite see how it works maybe there's a
trick i'm missing
so king f7 bishop c4 check king e7 now
yeah
and you defend the queen and maybe
there's still compensation after a move
like queen f2 but it clearly wasn't what
they had in mind right
but i think that that's what they're
gonna go for so yeah king here is the
only move i believe
so you have to play it and then queen
here and then i guess the key is how do
you defend that f7 square it's not so
easy
maybe because queen g6 allows the e5
pawn to drop right
and rook h7 allows the knight to drop so
maybe that's not so easy
yeah so queen f2 is probably a very
strong move here
because white's down a rook but there's
lots of compensation i feel
because here maybe 96 is the key
annoying move to block the bishop
but i don't know even there you have 94
perhaps
rook d1 is possible 96 is a strong move
though i think
that's the key because
it just blocks the bishop and gets a
piece off the back rank you're ready to
play rook f8
it just kind of makes things
things more tricky but i still think
white has to try queen f2 or maybe queen
f4 is actually more
pointed because then the e then the e
pawn is also hanging
yeah queen f4 is maybe stronger right
because if you play queen f4 then this
pawn hangs and now queen f7 is a thing
so if knight e6 for example you can play
rook takes e5 and your
pins galore right so queen f4 would have
been very very strong not so easy to
spot i should say
maybe after queen f4 you have to try
knight d7 with the idea that after queen
check you can go here
but one resource white has is you can
simply attack the rook and this rook is
impossible to defend i think
so queen f4 would have been very very
strong here i believe
but not again not so easy to spot right
and these guys do not have lots of time
so queen f2 looks very tempting but rook
h7 i don't think is best i think 98 i
think 96
and it's pretty good for for black but
rook h7 allows bishop takes knight
which i would take again it's only it's
still
down material but it's going to make a
big difference so bishop takes knight
rook g7 for example oh they missed it i
guess
yeah bishop takes knight rook g7 you can
play knight e4 and the idea is that if
the queen just moves somewhere
say g6 you can play queen f6 check and
you can't take back because the pawn
takes with a fork
so that's going to be quite painful i
think
so in general bishop takes g8 would have
been very good so bishop d3
brook f7 and now black's just kind of in
business because
they've gotten over the worst of it you
probably have to attack this pawn but
you can play
knight here next for example holding on
to your e5 pawn
so i think that this attack is slowly
getting
defeated but that's the thing when you
sacrifice a piece or a rook even if it's
really really strong
you there's not a lot of room for error
you have to be very very precise
so but i think that i think that black
just white just missed rook h7 was a
move so they therefore missed that this
night hung
uh it's very easy to do by
players of all levels i should mention
it's something that happens all the time
especially in blitz games so what do we
have this was a double forfeit that's
not ideal
and okay we had oh this was the last
game so we'll kill that that was round
one
uh okay so what else have we got
we can stick with this one it's still
interesting i guess but yeah so g6 so
as far as what to play here you might be
able to take this
ah no you should not take this because
knight takes
uh bishop queen takes and then queen
takes
e5 and you take this rook yeah so knight
takes would be a blunder but
what else can you do here maybe rook so
rook f6 does allow knight here
which isn't the end of the world but
it's annoying
maybe the rook should just come back
quite honestly
just make sure that pawn can't harm you
the other move i would consider is rook
f4
which also looks playable and that's
what he goes for which
probably is is also fine
so i don't know what i would try as
white now maybe queen e3 to hit the rook
and hit this pawn
so probably the king moves somewhere and
i take this pawn and i claim that i have
an uh another pawn to my name but quite
honestly
it's not inspiring but it's what i would
try queen e3 probably
okay he goes for a knight e4 but now
you're not really threatening much you
could even think about grabbing this
pawn if you're brave but you don't have
to right you can
play a more sane move like just move the
queen some safe square
and the problem is this knight looks
very pretty but you're also not
threatening anything and when you're
down
a rook you have to threaten things it's
one of the rules
hmm
all right
what other games have we got dv dutch
against
i am rounder
okay so this was yeah so you have a
position
when you when you do things like this
it's very tempting to just want to push
all your guys right
but the problem is that generally if you
try to push on all sides of the board
you won't be able to maintain
everything so what i would prefer is
something like knight b3
for example and then the idea is you're
eventually trying to shove with c4
with c5 rather this would be very
typical and then trying to play c5 and
try to improve on the queen side and
break down that wing
when you try to play with f4 you're
basically like trying to play
on the queen side and then on the king
side and in general you just create too
many weaknesses when you do this
so even if there weren't an
instantaneous tactic here which there is
i i just don't really like this approach
because
you you're trying to you have to guard
all these squares right like if your
palmer back here and your knight were
over here
which i understand is not realistic when
playing f4 but say your night work here
right and you add bishop takes and
knight here then it becomes at least
more viable
because here your bishop's here your
knight's pinned right this bishop is on
the long diagonal
you're just kind of asking for trouble
with moves like this so after takes f4
knight f3 it's not surprising that there
are tactics right
if rook takes you could have played many
things but even knight takes d5 with
this
again skewer it's just really annoying
right
so it's just something to avoid in
general
because yeah this is just too much
material so here
okay yeah probably too much
bishop d4 check king h1 knight back okay
i don't know what knight back
probably you just let your opponent take
this rook right
even if you go back to g7 right you play
bishop g7 you allow them to take the
rook
you take you're up a full piece so after
rook here you can even take this pawn i
think because if rook check knight f8 i
mean
you're not going to have enough for a
piece there i don't believe
maybe there was a cleaner way to do this
around here for example bishop f6 was
probably just winning
on the spot but
yeah so now it's not as clear i suppose
because
black's have two puns but they're not up
a piece so there's still
room for counter play and things like
this uh but it's still two pawns it's
still very good
so something like e8 is possible
any kind of normal move here is fine
bishop here is fine
if you want to make sure that guy
doesn't hang anymore although it's not
currently takeable of course because the
pin
so yeah definitely very good
just browsing these other games seeing
if there's anything worth
noting
all right
yep so rookie eight and this is a nice
move because if white tries to do this
and tries to
get the queen in you can always trade
queens and having the option to trade
queens is always nice when you're
up material and but you could get
attacked if you're not careful so white
actually tries to
play knight c2 to prevent this but quite
honestly it's probably too little too
late
you could probably grab this pawn if you
feel like it but you also don't have to
right you can play a move like knight d7
just guarding the f6 square and making
sure nothing horrible happens to you
although i don't really know how
anything horrible happens i think you
have to
you'd have to blunder or something but
it's always something to look out for i
suppose
um let's see
what other games have we got one thing
black has to be careful of though is
their time they're down to
two and a half minutes compared to
white's seven and it's nice to be able
to play
take that time and play stronger moves
but then you have to make sure you
finish off the game because
if you don't finish off the game well
you're down on time a lot
and sometimes then that costs you the
game this is something i'm very well
aware of especially in blitz
in long time control games i tend not to
do that but in blitz i'm down on time
all the time so
i understand fully but it's still
winning you play knight d7 for example
you just make sure you don't get
bankrupt mated you make sure nothing bad
happens but the bishop controls the
square so there's never rookie two
the key is just you don't allow black to
white to do anything too horrible to you
on the dark squares but you can play for
example knight d7 and after the bishop
moves
95 is probably quite good
so they play queen takes rook f4 but now
you have queen e2
which should take care of it because
you're threatening the queen trade and
yeah so you could trade queens and try
to play rookie 2 to
rikki 47 but the problem is after bishop
d3 rookie 8 takes the knight
you can only win your piece back and
even though it's opposite bishops you're
down
about five zillion puns so it's just not
not gonna quite work out
but once again right when you have a
lost position you have to lose somehow
sometimes and
sometimes you play a move that it
doesn't draw but it doesn't allow a
couple wins so they have to find one win
or two wins that work and that's
sometimes the best you can do
so here i would maybe try queen c3 just
to try to keep pieces on the board even
though it means i might just get mated
and my idea is that if they allow me
i'll play this move
and that move will be quite annoying
trying to threaten mate so it's at least
the way to make a threat i don't think
that it should be good enough
but it's a way to make a threat and that
sometimes that's just all you need to
try
uh white instead goes for this line
where they trade queens but
it's probably not good enough so here
the key is just you don't allow rookie 4
right so something like bishop d3 makes
sense you can play knight d7 attacking
the bishop
you just don't allow the rook in because
that's when complications arise right so
you play something like
knight d7 to attack the bishop or you
try to play bishop d3 to keep the rook
out
so 97
bishop to d8 makes sense trying to go
after these pawns
and black just surrenders the pawn but
i'm not so sure
after bishop takes c7 for example
it looks like it's going to be kind of
problematic because the pawn on d6 is
not so easily guarded so
this position maybe you should try c6
the idea being you're trying to just
trade off these pawns so after here
you're just going to take
and again it's it should be too many
puns but it's still complicated this
though
ah so he i think he's missing and this
is what happens when you get low on time
you get panicky
and i'm suspecting this is what happened
because black played very well all game
but then this position they start to
panic and that's what can happen right
so knight c4 is kind of a panic move
here maybe you should try knight d3
i'm not sure though honestly because if
something like rookie 4 bishop takes d6
it's very complicated
now bishop takes d6 immediately sorry
like rook d4 and then bishop takes d6
but this is already a lot of counter
play because the the d6 pawn is gonna
hang probably you should just go back to
d7 so you don't
you know and bishop here and just try
not to allow something horrible but this
is already very
messy so now white's probably winning
because
extra piece is quite meaningful here so
let's see what happens rook takes f7
yeah getting the king cut off also is
quite strong because now you can start
to make mate threats for example you can
play rookie 7
sometimes and then try to get the knight
in you have to be careful of this move
though
but maybe you just ignore the pun and
you just try to mate that's probably
what you should do so something like 98
or 94 now
i like knight e4 it seems decent
although 98 is kind of clever okay they
just take the pawn
but now you you deal with this right
that's the one issue
okay but again black's main issue is
time they have 12 seconds left and
that's probably gonna cost them the game
i would suspect
uh so even if they create counterplay
here yeah so here you can play bishop d6
or you can play bishop e5 at night here
and just try to mate your opponent
which i guess is what they're going for
right so if takes then you play knight
d6
oh wait this is meeting two oh this is a
nasty mate in two rook check and then
knight here is mate
wow that's a very unusual pattern
that's very nice easy to miss though
very very easy to miss
so yeah that would have been quite nice
but knight d6 immediately is also quite
strong i think
but he plays rook g7 and then knight d6
instead okay still very very
powerful takes the pawn yeah and
just too little time and he's lost so i
don't think that this is going to be
saved
so tough tough loss because black
definitely
was doing very well that game but once
again time can really
can really get you in these situations
so
uh moving on to this last one
so here we have a game where white's up
upon
but it's also and is also up on time
which might be more relevant because 50
seconds
isn't a lot i would say that in general
this is gonna be a hard pawn up position
to one because this a7
to win sorry because the save five pawn
is quite weak but i think you have to be
careful like this move i actually don't
like and the reason why is because now
you can check
and bring the rook to the seventh and i
think that's going to be really really
strong because you're just going to take
all these pawns
i think the better defense here would
have been rook to c7
and just try to leave the position as is
because you're keeping the rook so it
tries
to guard your pawns and if white wants
to try to activate the rook to force you
to take
and then let you take the pawn that's
fine but at least there your rooks
guarding the seventh rank
so after rook a4 uh white has some time
to think which they're wisely using but
i think a move like rook czech is
actually quite nasty because if you go
king c6 then rook b6 check and you take
this pawn
if you go king c5 i can which maybe is
the best i can still go here
and my rook's just gonna wreak havoc on
that seventh rank
so white goes for this but now i thought
you could take this
uh taking this is also good yeah so c4
check was a bit of a mistake
because c4 rook b2 check you can always
go back right like that's not
all that dangerous so c4 check was a bit
panicky i think rook b2 check
followed by rook b7 and it would have
been good for white
whereas now because you block the rook
it's definitely not so clear
uh but he's allowing rook back yeah
probably in this position you have to go
look back yourself just to keep
kind of keep an eye on these pawns
because i don't think that this
end game should be bad for you after
check check and take the rook
right yeah cause you have an outside
password that should be good for black
so
probably black white would just try to
activate the rook something like this
and it's probably
a good position for white but at least
if you can get your king up and start
pushing at some point
uh not right away as long as there's
rook be to check but
so king v6 tried rookie seven and now
black's trying to get counter play with
the pawn
uh which is what they have to do the
problem is it is just one pawn
uh but i guess they have a nice trick
here if king c3 you have this
but i think what white would probably
just do is is just come back
so rook here but maybe rook b2 is a
thing
interesting maybe white had to be a
little bit more cautious
yeah so for example one thing i would
probably do is in this position after 85
i might just play king here
because then they have to worry about
how does how do i actually do anything
with this a pawn
um but okay i mean
ah so they're thinking of taking a draw
here
so i don't know how how would you go
about winning this so king c3 a3
then maybe rook here ah he doesn't go
for it
yeah i think a3 if takes a2 you have to
force
ah this doesn't even force a draw you
actually just get queen done so a3 then
it forces this
oh no but then a2 actually this might be
losing after a3
i think black might be winning after
that because if you try to play a slow
move like rook here i can play rook
behind the pawn and then just push
so a3 might have been winning wow but
with so little time it's so hard to play
a move like that you know because you
have to be sure
and it's really difficult to do that
okay so all right allows a3 but here you
can at least get the rook behind the
pawn
so you're not just losing or anything
like that
but this end game i'd say is probably
better for black if you get in rook
takes ponce and pawn push because you
have a very very strong a2 pawn and the
rook
wreaks havoc along the second rank so
yeah this is very oh this is a very
clever
move because now if rook takes pawn you
play rook chick takes and here
so he plays f4 which is probably the
correct defense but now you check and
take
and uh really interesting rook end game
these guys are playing
yeah but this is going to be very very
difficult because this a3 pawn is
probably just going to
create a queen here so rook b3 good
technique and now he's going to play
rook b2 here the problem is his time
right
so checks in a2 i think should be good
although this f-pawn is actually quite
fast no
maybe it's a bigger problem than i
thought
wow not so easy
yeah there's probably an easier way to
do it around here but not not
simple with no time
yeah so it was time that undid him in
the end but this was a very
very very strong idea of just pushing
this pun
so not exactly sure how i would have
gone about this at the end it's
very tricky yeah
not so simple but quite a quite an end
to that game so
the next games they they seem to want to
start right away so we don't have to
take a break and look at the games
but quite something but to go over the
standings briefly
uh so enterprise and edward jones tied
with two against two
so and then in the other one
worldwide technology won their match two
and a half one and a half against maritz
so uh our standings let us see if
they're updated yeah
so our standings edward jones and
worldwide technology are leading with
one and a half points each
and enterprise and it has one point and
maurits has
zero so let's see what the last round
pairings are we have
edward jones plays worldwide technology
so the
basically that's the match we're gonna
focus on
so edward jones against worldwide
technology
so that's v shall against mjc alex
kurford against dv dutch
uh justine linguini against old path and
fishers of men against derek for free so
we're gonna try to
concentrate on those games in particular
because that seems to be the
the top fight although we'll definitely
keep an eye on merits against enterprise
if there are any interesting games
uh for sure
all right
so let us see uh the games have not
started yet
hello how's it going
i assume the games will be starting any
minutes
all right just waiting for the players
so if you have any questions now is a
pretty good time
but yeah in the end it all comes down to
edward jones against worldwide
technology
and if they do tie their match though if
they tie their match to two then we get
to see an armageddon playoff between one
player on each team which is also
very cool
all right taking a five minute blake
thank you nicholas
so the players are taking a break i
don't blame them this is 10 minutes
with zero second increment this is
exhausting stuff
so they've more than earned their break
but
really entertaining games to watch you
just don't see
you know i would say that players who
are say under 2000
which i think most players in this are
are they just don't get
the spotlight that much they don't get
you know people going over their games
and things like this so it's kind of a
nice opportunity because it's something
different
and i would say that in general other
than the very elite gm's other
groups of chess players don't get that
as much and it's kind of a nice thing
because you just get a different view
um because obviously like when i'm doing
commentary i'm gonna miss a lot of
things right
but at the same time you get a view of
like how you know some random gm like
myself would
just view the games as they're looking
at them and things like this
hey bo uh all right
but let's see if there are any
interesting games to go over
all right yeah let's see alex crawford
against chess
hulky how did this go
uh okay
so they got
okay kind of an unusual setup yeah in
general this is not really the way i
would want to play a stonewall
um i guess it's not terrible but the
problem is you're still giving black
options of cracking you with something
like this and sometimes that's
pretty annoying i would say though from
black's point of view taking this pawn
is a little bit strange for me
because not that it's horrible right you
can take the pawn and play d5 and life
is very normal
but one thing i would say is that you
just don't
in general when your opponent plays with
e3 you want to leave them with that pun
because it keeps the bishop blocked
right so if you can play a move like say
g6 here would be normal you could play
d5 if you want
you can also defend your pawn right you
can play b6 and it's not a terrible move
at all
uh i don't believe so you just have lots
of options but i would say that in
general leaving your opponent with the
pawn on e3 is kind of nice
not that you have to right but but yeah
playing with f4 kind of has some
some it's a little bit of an odd
stonewall i would say but
it's not terrible or anything so
this is all kind of normal um
oops why do i keep doing that
sorry guys so we have this kind of
interesting middle game so the main
thing though is almost always in a
stonewall you want to try to get
to e5 at least because then you're it's
just a pesky piece to deal with because
you don't want to play f6 and weaken
yourself and otherwise you have to allow
takes and pawn takes so you have to
leave them with that great knight
so knight takes would be my instinct at
least
because here you don't really want to
develop the bishop on the queen side you
want to keep it on the king's side so
i don't know i mean ideally white would
want to play g4 here and maybe try to
play with f5 you can also
think about trying to maneuver the
knight so move the rook and put the
knight on g3 would be pretty normal and
then try to play f5 at some point
but really because everything's pointed
over here you have the pawn chain
pointing towards the
king side you have the bishops pointing
towards the king side the king side's
really the side white wants to play on
and it's very important i think that
they do so
after this again the bishop on b2 is
just not that great of a piece because
this pawn on d4 is just going to be a
weakness now i would say
so knight b6 i don't know about this
exactly but
maybe you could play
it's a very tricky position it's it's
not
super simple
in general i would like to open this
side of the board i'm even considering
takes in b5 although that's
a little bit much maybe even queen a5
just kind of moves to keep pressure on
the center because you really want to
just move your queen so say queen a5 or
some move like this and then
bring the rook to the center and put
pressure on the d-pawn right okay but
we're having things start so we're going
to look at
so v shall derek for free against fishes
of men
uh so just to make sure yeah these are
the right games right
okay so we're going to stay focused on
this so we have v shawl against mg
mjc i think this is the
top board from that section
all right so let's check it out yeah i
don't know why his radix 800 is
obviously a lot better than that but i'm
assuming it's provisional
so we have g3 bishop g2 castles e6
knight bd2
bishop to d6 so
all kind of normal
so bishop d6 rookie one knight f6 so
yeah it's really important for white
that they try to get in an e4 move here
it's just the only way that their
position makes a lot of sense so trying
to play with knight
h4 is is pretty logical i would say
if you're going to play this way so
h3 c3 there are lots of different
options you can play with queen b3 and
e4 is maybe what he's going to try
you can also play with g4 of course and
try to just
play uh to just take this bishop but
it's always a little bit feels a little
bit weird sometimes to give up this
bishop but
it's uh pretty tricky so let me move
back
wait is this an error oh shoot
okay thank goodness
okay so yeah g4 is is quite interesting
uh which is what he tries and then
bishop back
i believe i don't think you want to
start sacking things yet
uh
yeah it's funny as i would always
consider it but yeah now now you yeah
and then now you play e4 so this is kind
of normal
but it's also a little bit risky because
your king's side is always a little bit
open right so they're going for this
kind of normal setup
and now probably black black's gonna
castle queen side i would guess
because the king side's always going to
be a little bit dicey for white and then
you can
even knight d5 and put the knight on f4
this is the kind of position where white
has the two bishops but i don't think
it's clear that white's doing that
fabulously
uh and it's again because of these
slightly weak squares
sometimes there are also ideas of just
going here to trade off this bishop
sometimes just trading off the two
bishops is a very very nice idea
but again there are lots of different
options castling queenside can't be
wrong i don't think castle and king's
side is probably not horrible but i
don't prefer it i prefer castling
queenside which is what he does
so let's see b4 okay so he starts his
attack which is very logical
so now the question is do we play with
bishop f4 do we play with knight d5 i
kind of like knight d5 myself
because you're attacking these pawns
right and i think that attacking these
pawns makes a good deal of sense
um but there's no huge threat right if
b5
in in a lot of these positions you're
going to respond to c5 and it's not bad
because your lines are kind of closing
so i don't think there's an immediate
need to do anything crazy but at the
same time
you know it's still very possible
so yeah tricky position definitely one i
would think a little bit in so a move
like bishop f4
is also possible he goes for e5
which to me looks a little bit early
but it's also a very much very much a
reasonable idea in general
i would more be worried about just
bishop e3 here quite honestly
than taking this pawn but after bishop
b3 the main problem i have with this is
that it feels like the position is going
to open up in the center which is not
exactly what black wants because then i
think
there's going to be more issues
involving the king side so for example a
bishop takes
if pawn takes bishop takes i don't know
if that's a good development
and here if you play knight here i
probably can think about taking it at
least
because i forced you to take with the
pawn and then i can try taking and
actually wait a second that's going to
be a little risky maybe knight d5 is
actually
i keep sometimes i forget that my king
side is very loose right
okay so he goes for this which is fair
yeah i'm not exactly sure quite honestly
hmm
so yeah you could think about taking i
guess but it's
it's it's very possible right this is a
big decision so it takes takes takes i
don't think you can play rook takes pawn
right away
that looks like too much he goes for it
um
it's a very very crazy position guys
i don't know it looks a little too much
for white probably here you have to try
something else
yeah it's it's a little bit difficult to
to suggest like a great option here but
this planet position is very tricky to
play for white honestly
so queen f3 to queen g2 but this looks
like a disaster in the making this is
going to be just crushing
so i think that probably black's winning
here i would imagine yeah this is
basically going to be over so putting
the bishop on g5 is a nice try though
that's probably the best defense but
quite honestly the problem is this pawn
is just gonna murder you when it when it
moves forward
and there's not that much you can really
do about it
so very very nice play by black this
game
so i'm trying to figure out what i would
do is white maybe i would try
yeah i think here i would have tried
rook c1 with the idea of frc4
just to try to open up some lines for
yourself and make it so it's not so
one-sided a4 is just very very slow
so now ideas of f4 f3 are going to be
quite strong you don't even have to play
it right away
you could play queen d7 first for
example or other moves but
that's going to be the idea that that
will scare black
that will scare white greatly or at
least it should
so it goes for bishop f4 which is kind
of interesting i guess it's probably
also quite strong right
there's not too many ways you go wrong
with a position like this
so i don't know what exactly you should
try here maybe bishop takes queen takes
and then
rookie three with the idea that after
the queen moves preparing f4 so say
queen h4 you can play rook g3 and try to
get your rook in
uh that would at least be a reasonable
try i believe
but it's still very difficult this
position so takes queen takes rookie
three is what i suspect will happen
uh let's see if we have any so we have a
couple results dv dutch one and chess
hulky one but let's see if
yeah ah so dv dutch
so dv dutch one
[Music]
against
oh no this was the previous round
okay uh chelsea won against i am rounder
so that was that
okay but let's see so where were we
all right alex stevie dutch so this game
is really important as well
and it looks like white's in some
trouble here the
the white king looks very suspicious
uh and the e3 pawn is quite weak so
there are things like queen c3 check and
night gear coming in
uh but let's find the game where we were
shawl against mjc
here we are so we have queen to f
for bishop takes queen takes c4 was
tried fair enough
so then rook h5 and then king f1 yeah
the problem is this is coming a little
bit too fast
it looks like
so i don't know what exactly what the
best move here it's very tempting to go
here because you actually force queen h1
which is very sad
but i don't really see an alternative
and maybe there's no
killer follow-up is the idea but it
looks
a little depressing it's one of those
positions where maybe it's survivable
but you
don't really it looks so horrible that
you just don't want to go for it but
maybe it's it's what you have to do but
okay rook here king queen here i don't
see the knockout blow to be fair
it wouldn't surprise me if there is one
ah it goes for queen f3 which is quite
interesting the idea is after takes
takes
you're gonna basically claim the kings
in a bit of a body bag and you're just
gonna
build your position like this and
there's not a whole lot
white can do about it so probably you
can't take that the problem with this
move i thought was rookie 3 though
but i suppose there if you have to you
can just trade queens and play f4 and
claim your positions good but i
definitely don't think
that's the cleanest maybe it works
though because the pawn lands on f3 and
you're
probably st your king's still really
uncomfortable i would say
so yeah maybe this is a really really
clever idea queen g3 queen f3
and the point is if you allow this then
you just lose so you have to do
something
um
very really cool idea queen f3
especially in a rapid game i mean it's
not easy to come up with these kind of
moves
so rookie three though i think would be
the best bet he takes there
ah because you're attacking the rook i
suppose but
this looks like it's gonna end very
badly somehow
but okay you have to find the right move
so he plays rook there which i guess
works i was thinking of this
because then if you play rook here
debate the point is that
you don't want to allow rookie 3 and
then if queen check queen g1 and maybe
you're surviving
so i wanted to play queen check first
because then if the king goes to this
direction if king g1 for example you can
actually play rook back and you're
threatening to like do this
which is absolutely crushing right so
queen d3 and if k
rook here now you can play say rook
rook h1 and then there's no rookie 3
there's nothing and queen h3 is a huge
threat so that maybe would be my choice
but rook h1 maybe is good enough
okay he takes
i thought rookie three would be the move
with the idea of queen check rook here
i mean okay rook takes h3 should be
winning but it's maybe not
no i mean that's oh no you could just
trade queens and play f4 f3 that's
gonna be disgusting yeah okay so it
takes d5 maybe the best shot then
uh he's really defending well
considering the quality of his position
but okay queen takes h3 wins right
because of king e2 oops sorry
if king e2 then queen mates right
and if you block with the queen then i
play queen check
and that should be the end of days i
suppose he plays queen d3 check first
which i
think should work as well but king g1
and at least you don't have a check here
right the whole
idea of checking here first is that
after queen g2 you have to retreat so
after queen check
king g1 you're not threatening anything
right so it gives black a move to just
play something to try to win so say rook
h4 to g4 something like this right
should be winning for for instance i
mean probably there are other ways
so queen d3 king g1
and rook h7 this is probably also good
enough i would imagine
but this is very clever defense right
because if you allow check and check you
actually lose
uh one way to win maybe is with a6 but
that's very
cold-blooded so rook h7 looks like a
pretty good move so now if rook c1 check
for example king here queen shaq
king here you don't get mated but you're
about to
but maybe rookie three then
hm maybe he's still fighting so he
checks this way i didn't like this way
because i thought that here you want to
have this rookie 3 resource in your
pocket so i didn't think this was as
good
but wow he takes the pawn this i did not
expect
but i guess it's playable okay so check
king h2 and now what
wow this is some very resourceful plane
and this is now
not so simple i don't think so ricci
it's a threat so maybe you have to go
here but then you can play rook g1 or
something
yeah this was not not the clearest so
here
hm queen takes f5 yeah i think that the
key was in this position right
i think here the easiest was to take
this pawn first to force the queen to a
passive square
and i think then the win is a lot
simpler because the queen gets left on
an active square
it becomes much more pesky because this
is just annoying i mean now it's
really really challenging to to try to
win
because richie one's just coming right
if you're not sure and rook c8 check is
also a thing
maybe you have to go rook g8 just to
prevent back rank but then i can play
rook g1 or something like this and
it's not so simple ah but then rook f8
that's annoying
ah so probably rook g8 is the move here
but even here it's not so simple right
maybe d6 d7 is a is an idea
um trying to just launch and i don't see
how you get mated because if rook here
you can play d7 which
is very nice as a resource i think
um so yeah d6 was tried
so just to update you on the standings
for this particular
match so
alex curferd won
so that's edward jones gets a point so
he won
and what do we have here
yeah so then that's the only one from
this match so currently
edward jones is up one point and then v
shawl is on edward jones and it looked
like he was out of the game but he
played some excellent defense and now
it's not gonna be so simple so it's
really coming down to the wire i think
d7 is a very very strong move but let's
see because you have rook takes h3 check
is an idea
but i think queen takes h3 check rook
takes check king here
and you lose for black because
you're out of checks and i'm about to
queen on you so probably rook takes h3
doesn't work
so d7 looks very very powerful also note
that black only has a little over a
minute
so if v shawl wins this game as white
that turns around the whole match and
should make it so that it's like
edward jones is then up 2-0 all right so
one and a half sorry fishers of men drew
yeah so fishers of men drew so now
edward jones is up one and a half
to half against worldwide technology
and yeah if vishal wins this game which
he might at this point it looks like
edward jones clinches it so this is a
really important game the other game is
justini linguini which is an amazing
username i should just say
and it looks like he's in trouble though
like it looks like this is going to be
made right
so it looks like he's in trouble so it
actually all will come down to this game
of vishal against mjc
rook c8 trying his best i'm surprised he
didn't play with the rook so he could
try to run although i guess you can't
really ever run that's the problem
yeah because now the rook just moves
somewhere right and then
bishop here queen knight i don't know
it looks like you're going to get made
but let's see the v shell
yeah this looks like it's over
so we have queen e5 check back d7 queens
check yeah this is
this is over and now rook g1 for
instance you could play any move you
want
but this is going to be this is going to
be over
rook c1 he chooses which is also fine
yeah i mean again you have lots of ways
you can do this the simplest
as i said is just bring the queen back
like don't do anything too fancy
so let us see yep it looks like they're
going to get it and let's check out this
one
yeah i mean you probably have to try
knight d3 or something but it's
kind of rough sledding because even if i
go hear a check i just take your knight
and come back you're not going to
actually defend against mate here
so it really came down ah f6 is a move
though
yeah not so easy
ah underestimated f6
this definitely happens
hmm
okay so maybe even this one's not so
clear but i think v shawl should win
this anyway
pretty much every time but let's just
make sure
and this should clinch the match
for edward jones yep white wins
so congratulations to edward jones i
believe that they
are the winners so yeah edward jones
ends up with two and a half out of three
and i believe that that is that is it
if i go to the standings yep error jones
with two and a half
uh two and a half out of three
enterprise
ends up with one and a half i believe
um or sorry worldwide technology ends up
with one and a half
enterprise won their match so they end
up with two and then maritz
uh ends up in last place so
congratulations once again to edward
jones
really really well played and really
interesting really resourceful last
round game by vishal here
um it looked like he was down and out
this game this game
i think it all hinged on this one
decision where it looked like black had
played excellently here and was about to
win queen f3 i liked
but this one move okay here he could
have checked probably but even here this
one move he had to take the h3 pawn
first to force the queen back and then
queen d3 check
that i think should have been winning uh
probably not the only win to be
perfectly honest even after queen h3
queen g2 i think queen takes queen
should win
uh the idea being king takes f4 or f3 is
gonna just be crushing
but okay i mean there are lots of ways
to win but the problem with queen d3
check was that it allowed this
resourceful idea
and then he found d6 d7 really really
nice
and this was just all she wrote so
quite a big turnaround in this game
really good defense uh and overall
congratulations to edward jones
uh so to name the players that we have
vishal uh
barad watch i'm sorry i'm really
butchering your names
i apologize uh alex kerfer alex kirford
who's actually the founder and was in
the chat so
thank you i hope you enjoyed the
commentary alex and then we have uh
justin beckstead was justine linguini
and
fishers of men was stephen evans so
congratulations to vishal
alex justin and steven really well done
i hope you guys enjoyed the commentary
and hopefully i can maybe do it again it
was a lot of fun to go over these games
i have to say
it was a lot of really a lot of really
interesting games a lot of
double-edged matchups and
you know just there was never a shortage
of interesting games to go over
so i thought it was quite good and again
it came right down to the wire
right down to that last one but once
again congratulations to edward jones
and i will be signing off now
so thank you and have a good one